yes yes yes
hey meme review
[Music]
dean norris the actor from breaking bad
this just in ism dean
[ __ ] norris d norris it's
this is it this is it a photo shoot from
like
six years ago has popping up everywhere
save image s web p
that's me when it has no [ __ ]
transparent background
no one antibacterial hand soap can you
find him
there he is right there
it's just the ultimatum of expression
right here
i feel like this would be the lamest
meme if you don't know who he is this is
so random
random reddit did it again i mean
zachary
there it is was waiting for it
this is how i actually imagined it no
[ __ ] this toothpaste this toothpaste
[ __ ] sucks
maybe we should just say that one
dentist doesn't lie i always thought
it's so weird
do you think they have they must
actually do the actual
statistics but it's almost just like one
nine out of ten dentists recommends
right
it almost feels like it's too uh it
seems to like we paid them off or
something maybe we should add that one
of them didn't like it right
one of the dentists doesn't like him i
[ __ ] hate it
what is this flavor would not recommend
a photographer took a picture of a man
before
and after taking his minerals before and
after g-fuel
check it out link in the description
yeah i can make memes
i can make jokes spending billion
dollars on a submarine to swim 100 miles
and crash it buying five kebabs for ten
dollars
i get it because i've seen jojo have you
seen jojo
great anime it's funny because it's true
oh my god
my own [ __ ] discord does this and
it's so annoying
stop adding me at the discord i'm too
old to understand this chord i don't
know how to turn it off
stop it five second unskippable add 15
seconds skippable ad after five seconds
don't mind if i do skipping the ad right
as it's finished
can i do that face i feel like i have
that dramatic lightning in here it's not
very
flattering is it
man just just woke up one day and
decided to
[Music]
now that's acting
pooping peeing i do that
so uh it's funny too because he's
embraced the meme on twitter
before the kids put it out there he did
the thing
he did the thingy oh cyber sent me this
and i i don't understand but apparently
dean norris
back in may 23 2018 tweeted sex gifts
this isn't okay i get it
dean norris no sex
games
that's [ __ ] funny he left it up i
respect that
hell yeah
thank you side that's hilarious actually
dean explain yourself
that's [ __ ] crazy okay i respect this
man
and i was online gaming one hour of
online class
no thank you cleaning a room cleaning a
room after someone says to clean it
okay all right all right all right
we we get it thank you i rate this
that was so random thank you
[Music]
all right let's get into the good [ __ ]
so i heard about this
this is the great josh fight it started
off
with a text message in a group chat with
josh josh
josh josh joshua josh josh you're
probably wondering
where i gathered you are here today
because we all share the same names
precisely the 24th of april 2021 12pm
meet at these coordinates we fight
wherever wins gets to keep the name
everyone else has to change their name
you have a year to prepare good luck so
this has been brewing for a [ __ ] year
i didn't realize that that's funny
josh versus all the josh's who's the
greatest josh i want to know
who is the greatest josh this is what
people were imagining the fight would be
the thing is people have prepared
similar stuff like this
we see facebook inmates of events and
even the area 51 raid wasn't even that
you know we did get that one guy running
across which is funny but it
it wasn't even that great let's get real
here so expectations were close to none
for the josh fight
right oh there we go perfect yeah
that's a good meme april 23rd there are
65 people in the u.s named joshua swain
april 25th there's one what happened
here
65 joshua swain used to live here
[Music]
[Applause]
now no no
to everyone's surprise it was a great
[ __ ]
turnout and a lot of people came up
absolute
josh pitt at lincoln air park on
saturday josh pay
spidey josh
to compete in the ultimate showdown i'm
coming from minnesota
i'm coming all the way from dallas so
i'm from omaha i'm from wichita kansas i
do four and a half hours to be here
and of course worth it so it's almost
like there's a lot of josh
out there hey you're not a josh or maybe
she is i don't judge josh wayne of
arizona i'm feeling pretty insane right
now it's got so he's the guy that
started it
wayne of omaha took a year to begin
josh's from all over
gathered in a circle to compete in a
noodle fight
all right so how many how many people
died in an intense competition the
tiniest competitor four-year-old josh
vincent jr
hey he's actually known as little josh
came out victorious
that's sweet supreme josh that can only
be one
there was only ever really one we'll
leave to see the of pewdiepie versus
now we get to see a civil war of judges
around the globe
that's [ __ ] great love that little
josh
josh on your thoughts on the big win
the pig wind
[Applause]
[Music]
that guy must have had the best day of
his life that's great hey there's
little josh haters rigged get out of
here
we all know he demolished everyone fair
and square not the burger king hat no
no nope nope nope
no whoever did that you know what you
did you fell
you fell stinch well the josh meme
is great i read it great it's great it's
fantastic
next meme
[Music]
we've all seen the whatsapp ice cream
flavor
we've all seen the whatsapp slippers
but now we have the whatsapp drip car
hell yeah but wait there's more snapchat
drift card no way
okay got a good vibe
i like it
[Music]
oh
oh hell yeah
uh-huh i don't need skype anymore but
maybe i will
ah [ __ ] nah [ __ ] that [ __ ]
[Music]
oh it's like an underwater level
uh huh okay
no [ __ ] the apple drip what about steam
[Music]
sounds like a [ __ ] jingle bells
awful awful
oh hey
but my personal favorite snap card rip
[Music]
oh oh [ __ ]
right right out for start please four
guarantee it 10 out of 10. i read
10 up sorry 4 stars guarantee it
all right so this meme i am so [ __ ]
thankful
that we're finally addressing this
properly because it's something that's
annoyed me
for so [ __ ] long and i mentioned it
in my mildly infuriating video because
now this has become a meme
me googling transparent images fake pngs
why the [ __ ] are there fake pngs i don't
get it
i will never understand it and i want
you all to die
that sounded a little harsh because it
is it needs to be
and now thanks to memes people are
finally talking about it
it's a png i swear you're lying
it's got the [ __ ] chessboard
background stop it
i'm sick of it i wish fake png images
with a transparent checkerboard
background
get banned off google images no not just
banned killed
sent to an island at least you know how
to send people australia back in the day
can we do that
send them off to australia something
needs to be done that's all i gotta say
i don't know what the solution is
good morning to everyone but the guy who
makes fake transparent png
inches you are truly the lowest scum in
history
this is the worst we found it if there's
any
all this cancelling that's going on can
we put that to good use
hello me looking for a transparent image
yeah why is it always there and i don't
get it
i don't [ __ ] get it and i said this
before i google arrow
because i want a [ __ ] arrow in my
thumbnail and this [ __ ] show that i
will never ever ever ever ever ever ever
ever watch i've seen their goddamn
million times get this [ __ ] out of my
day
all right oh good look transparent image
that their
copy image put that into photoshop right
okay here i go i paste it
no one's talking about this either huh
why can't i copy
a [ __ ] png why does it do
that why is it black why i gotta save it
and import it nah fam
nah why what is an svg
it's either a jpeg or a png get the [ __ ]
out of here svg
we don't need new image formats thank
you very much
get out of here svg go away svg no one
asks for you svg you're the lowest of
the low of the scum of the earth
god damn it i hate it so much
look at this one this is a fake png
because i've fallen for the trap
before look oh yeah google things is
chromatic forming
so dumb that's another why free
transparent png they said
okay who did this clipart max click bar
max
you're dead to me clickbait max okay
maybe if i click on no i can't right
click on it
[Music]
they don't even let you right click on
it i never seen that before
oh my god you're dead you're death i
hate you
person that makes fake transparent png
images arrives in hell satan
well i just want to say i'm a huge fan
love your work
i love when i'm looking for a png and it
has a fake transparent background who
does that
do you also enjoy stepping on legos what
is wrong with you
i need answers i think that's it it
should be a legal slide
it should be that's completely [ __ ]
useless
png the png stop it
ah i just want to end on that note
fake png it's a zero oh and also
rickrell
zero okay now it's done thank you for
watching meme review if you enjoyed my
black drug
see you tomorrow bro face